[Music]
this week we've got
racist plates free money
and flying pasture there's so much
racism today
all right first story kansas officials
have sent out letters to 731 drivers
asking them to turn in their license
plates because it included
a race like an ethnic slur
at the end of it what does it say that's
tight oh it's because it's like
when they print them out it's like
randomized and they just all had like
[ __ ] at the end or something it's three
letters
oh no let us guess
b no [ __ ] what's a three
letter racist one oh is it f-a-g
no ethnics oh ethnic i think but that's
still bad yeah yeah yeah
you guys can do it i believe in you jay
jack jack
yeah yeah j-a-p yeah i've seen it
everywhere
kansas jack 170 jack 170 jab that's
tight
is japan ethnic slur yeah it is yeah
hell yeah
even though it's just short it's just
short come on dude no no it was it was
used in world war
ii as a slur that's pearl harbor oh
there's a lot
of history there yeah so a member of the
japanese american citizens league
saw one of these kansas plates here
in california in culver city yeah and so
that's when they brought the attention
oh especially like the west side asians
they're gonna be on that play they don't
play with [ __ ] around no yeah so they
contacted
kansas and then that's when they were
i don't know that that's like other
japanese gangs i bet there are yakuza
that's yeah oh yeah it's like a
randomized plate right it's it's not
yeah so that's like having a uh driver's
license and in in the driver's license
this is [ __ ]
in between or something on that yeah but
if there's a lot of them that's like
okay we get it's an accident please
change it because it could be like b-n-r
for [ __ ]
or something let's try it it's like
that's a little bit off but it feels
like fba
it's a stretch it's destroyed it feels
like sag and you're in west hollywood
and there's like yeah
there's like 700 [ __ ] license plates
let's be careful that's a lot let's be
careful that'd be crazy if it was like
[ __ ] 69
imagine how many tickets you'd get out
what's wrong with you man i don't know
dude your mind's not right man
you know what man what are you eating
what's up with this is it
what's happening it's all the vegetables
that's wrong man if that license plate
that's so wrong
if that license if that license plate
said 187
[ __ ] then i'd be like they bought this
[ __ ] license plate dude what's 187
murder murder kill homicide it's a
police call for homicide
oh man yeah so then that's when the
department
yeah of transportation they issued
this recall and they're so they're
saying that they're urging drivers to
come in and trade in their license plate
for a different one but whoever doesn't
do it by the next time that they get
their new registration they're going to
be issued a new license plate oh cool
okay yeah yeah it happens if it's an
accident it's an accident what if there
are like actual racist people and
they're like
[ __ ] i wanted that one i wanted to keep
it
it's like a special they're like oh you
got it yeah oh man
i wanted that who took kale jabs
son of a [ __ ] i wanted that one that's
crazy dude i didn't damn i didn't know
people had no idea this existed yeah
i would never want to have a license
plate that's easily like
notable same you know what i mean like
you want me there oh because the cops
yeah because everybody's going to
remember fact 69 when you're well you
guys have your back
yeah we got a bears one you got a what
you're wait what do you guys got
everything that's on my car is like just
super generic because i don't want to
stand out
yeah yeah you don't but i'm also a cute
[ __ ] so i was just like let's
get the best license
i want a message i also got like 17
speeding tickets
like i remember when we'd be in public
they'd be like oh we saw the bail mobile
so we knew you guys would be around
yeah that was this guy's idea yeah if
you're a really cute [ __ ] though
you put some barriers on that car dude
oh that'll be good barriers
some bail ears
you're done it did sound like berries
it's done no but i got i like the
balance
it's got to be like a gangster has
murdered our car and then
[Music]
you should get a car that looks like
tyka's helmet that's what i say that's
so cute
oh my god no yeah we wanted to go we
wanted the dumb and dumber uh
van yeah the puppy one yeah
you need to balance that one out if i
got that van then my license plate would
be two middle fingers yeah
and when it rains it looks like a wet
dog well we live in kelly
so i mean i'm raining today it's raining
hard today it's all right so it's just
gonna be a dusty dog
i don't have its dog wash yeah it was it
was coming down yesterday though
like it was last night yeah oh we were
asleep yeah i didn't even hear it
i was out i was playing um i was uh i
was playing boggle with my nephew
and uh what's bob is that yeah what is
bog it's kind of like scrabble
you press something right no yeah yeah
it's like you have is it a board game
you have a bunch of letters in the box
and you shake it and then when the
letters settle you have to make words
out of it is it isn't it oh
fun it's
i was playing the game with them right
and then he likes to sound out his words
so we're here like trying to figure out
what words there are
and then there was one he was like
you know what i'm talking about [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then how old is he uh like
nine or eight
oh he doesn't know what he's talking
about no well he did because then he was
like
[ __ ] like he was just spell like he just
spells it out and tries to make a word
and then it was n-i-g-r
what was that when you sound it out so
he said the word and then he was like
me and then he said the whole thing and
he went
oh man he knows what he said out loud
yeah good and then all of all of his
sisters looked at him like what the hell
did you just say and i'm like wow you
guys know that word
damn i remember when i yeah kids learn
the kids yeah go ahead that's good i'm
glad he knows it's better
to think that people said mega they'd be
like mega you
crazy mommy why do people call each
other mega that's hilarious
oh who you did or isaac isaac did right
yeah that's so innocent
looks i thought you said that no no
isaac i'm like cause there's a tupac
song where he spells it out for you
i want to be your n-i-g-g-a so we can
smoke we the [ __ ]
all day so he spells it out for you so
i'm like if in our generation
we had instructors that explained it you
know no he just
asked me like mommy why do people call
each other mega all the time like what
do you mean
that's when he's like yeah like you know
i hear people say mega you crazy
mega please mom oh like mega man
maybe that's what he was thinking oh
anyway moving on
next story there was this atm that was
malfunctioning oh my god that's a dream
come true
this is the next story okay
yeah you gotta you gotta rinse the
palette no no because this is a new
format this is new for me oh yeah he
hasn't done a weekend scrambling i
haven't done a scramble okay i'm here
so it's all one video okay
i'm here all right so this atm was
malfunctioning and
this happened in houston this man he
went to go pull out
money and so he requested ten dollar
bills
but instead of tens it was a hundred oh
so this guy i don't know why
bless you you're welcome okay so this
guy he
tweeted it out or like he's he told he
bragged about it
he's stupid exactly
they would have figured it out all these
people started bombarding this atm to
the point where cops had to come in and
like stop people
and it turns out that the person who
loaded up atm they obviously mixed up
the ten dollar bills with the hood
oh my god they're [ __ ] fired and in
prison
yeah so but you know the cool thing is
bank of america
is a bigger market you got insurance
also imagine bank of america is like
just
keep it you guys happy holidays
oh my goodness that's what i was about
to say keep it they told people they
could just keep it
no i don't believe that yeah so what's
the most
don't believe it's the most amount that
they wouldn't tell them oh come
on do you know how much they load up
atms with
no i can't i don't know that because do
you know we had a friend who
who did that like overnight she would go
and load up and count or
um she would just take the money out and
she would but she would count them
yeah yeah in a center she's not loading
she always miscounted them that's why
she got fired
oh cause now you can pick denominations
out of the atm now you can before it was
only 20
bills well that guy's so stupid instead
of they think they're getting a 10 they
got 100. yeah
i would have kept on taking out that's
whatever me too i would do 10.
why would you tell people and i would
have walked away
with so much money yeah and i would have
never told anybody
i can't do [ __ ] like that because my mom
brainwashed me she says every time you
steal something from
anyone or anytime you steal anything
you're going to lose something of
greater value
i didn't even see it as stealing well i
haven't stolen a day of myself stealing
because it's not
your money a day in my [ __ ] life and
jesus took both my ankles
so i don't know what the [ __ ] you should
be honest to be like hey someone made a
mistake this is
i was honest i'm trying to get a 10 out
and it absolutely give me 100. i'm sorry
if i did it like a thousand times
then you could be like hey i tried to
get a 10. here's your name
it's their fault let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question how
about here then all right how about here
how about those you know you got those
random days right you go to in and out
right you get a double double hell yeah
you know you're not supposed to
you eat it next day you stand on the
scale and you're like oh [ __ ] i lost two
pounds you try to give those two pounds
back
or you're just like hey i'll just take
it i don't consider that stealing i try
and you'll go back to entertainment back
i want to do it yeah so you try to get
you try to get
gain extra two pounds try to gain
exercise i'm not stealing those two
pounds you know what shocked me where do
they go you know what shocked me
i get lost i was i was at the self
checkout at ralph's with jess
and then there was two dollars hanging
out the the change thing
just pulled it out and i thought she was
gonna keep it because to me that's free
money
no she's not she went up to the person
in the counter and then gave it to them
good for you i was like that's awesome
she just brought good fortune to your
house
you should [ __ ] be great you know
what no i don't believe it because
i'm just like i was like what the [ __ ]
that's free money yeah but she also
throws away penny
yeah dude okay i got a story so no no no
she
she picks up coins though she picks up
five cents but she throws away pennies
so you know
you know what i used to do i just go to
chuck e cheese right and you do that
ball thing
chocolate cheese freaking out chucky's
like spitting out tickets i know
once that's spitting out tickets the
machine gears are in motion
i start pulling on it so instead of
getting like three tickets i'll get like
five
and look you got stuck with me can i get
up there if i get a bunch of them
i pulled out extra tickets so i me and
my homeboy jameel and um we went to asu
we were walking uh to play uh basketball
and we um
by this dumpster we found a lady's purse
and so we went in it
it was just there and oh that means
someone jacked her up
and then we said there's there's like
300 there's still money that's stealing
dude
and so we uh went back to my dorm room
and split it up
when when i know it's crazy that there's
a purse just sitting there
i know three hundred people i take money
if i know it belongs
she just got murdered no no no but we're
struggling call it we're struggling
okay what about this let's say you
bought universal lined it let's say you
bought you bought a car yep right yep
you just bought this car
and then in the back seat you open it up
there's a million dollars
yeah now what happened i have to give it
back oh that happened no
recently they bought a an old used
washing machine
and then inside of it there was hundreds
of dollars yeah then what do you do i
give it back
you crazy you guys are joking by now you
know you could trust me with
your money i already know i can trust
you with my money no it doesn't grow on
trees you're
not all going to steal from each other
all i'm saying is i'm on your team
whatever you say i'm with you okay if
all right how about this how about this
let's say hijackers right yeah
they [ __ ] jack some money and then
they're fighting in the air
and then it drops it drops randomly
marty just flies down from the sky
i don't want that bad juju no you know
what you're right
so with that one i have to keep it so if
i always scope out the scene and i
always look around i'm like [ __ ] who
looks like they just dropped something
nerd
okay let me ask you something if you saw
a briefcase like you're on a hike
that feels so bad you're on a camping
trip and you lose
see a briefcase filled with a million
dollars
nah i'm leaving it that's cartel money
i'm not touching no no no but it's all
crispy like
you know what i mean like perfect build
cartel money that is so you don't touch
the money
[ __ ] no what if you look around and you
go hey let's let's
live in a world of cameras these days no
no no but you camped there for a week
and you go let's leave it there for a
week
then i'm taking the money and then come
back and then when you're going back to
this you're making it more appetizing so
that we give you your ad
no one's no one's come for it in a week
what do you want us to say yes
i'm gonna dig a hole i'm gonna bury that
suitcase
come back a month later take a little
bit because they still haven't claimed
the briefcase
and then bury it back again i want to
know how much is a little 10 grand 10
grand how much is in the
a million dollars 10 grand is pretty
good they're not going to miss 10 300
dollars a week
what would you do just kidding
the million dollar suitcase how much if
you were to take some how much i'm gonna
take the whole thing
oh [ __ ] i don't want to die i'll take
the whole thing
and i'm gonna figure out a plan i'm
gonna take that first i'm gonna get a
bag
go to europe dude why europe
it's people usually it's less there it's
gonna be 300 000 there
i'm gonna go to like the southeast okay
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait you go to brazil i'm going to
philippines or brazil or something yeah
yeah something like that or korea yeah
with a million dollars yeah or japan
i'll go anywhere in thailand go to
thailand
japan i'll go i'll go to manila japan's
not expensive gotta go to places live
forever
in the philippines thailand you gotta go
to places where the money time it
becomes times ten
yeah you would return the money though
because you're on you would do it if
it's a briefcase i'm not touching that
because that's
that's why she looks innocent but she
got a dark side
you take a duffle bag there fill that up
with the money
leave the briefcase there there you go
because we left that lady's purse there
and her wall and our id
[ __ ] we just took the cash you
couldn't get no harm done there's no id
that is the r that's the only no there's
no harm done we didn't take that we left
that
why was a purse next to a dumpster he
was just murdered dude
so she doesn't need the money
your fast ass logic is hilarious i'm
sorry that's we're broke in college
i saw this one thing online though where
this guy got an email from someone who
stole their laptop
the guy was like hey listen i'm really
sorry i sold your laptop but i needed
the money but hey if it makes anything
better i did leave your cell phone and
your wallet there
that's that's what he would have done
let me know if there's any assignments
that you need i thought you're a college
student i'll email it to you i'm sorry i
took your laptop like that's just funny
that's you moving on yeah you got to do
the right thing if someone stole my
laptop
i just want them to have decency and put
all my
important [ __ ] on a hard drive and mail
it to me
and then clean out all of the [ __ ] in my
laptop same here
dude yeah all right so this is nice
okay this is fun i like this little
segment yeah these are fun well yeah one
more and then
cool cool all right so this is the last
story here this
church service has gone viral because
the pastor
sea walk battle he's zip lined in oh
i love this [ __ ] this is even better
yeah so i think that's great
this tastes like the hell yes that's
dope if i was a kid and i saw that
i wouldn't want to go to church
that's so distracting that's the coolest
passion he says he's like a prop pastor
his whole message is that jesus is
returning so he's like using the
ziplining it's lining
i'm too distracted i don't know what
he's saying i don't care that's the
coolest
pastor in the world what was his joke
no he's like are you ready for his
return that's when they should have
turned him but he just stays
that is a mega church dude dude they're
making money
they have money today
i love that is that the boys to men of
pastors
you know what the funny [ __ ] is you know
you know you know how he's hanging there
it looks like a kid getting picked up
by his parent and he's being lifted yeah
that's a great
church service that's that's like a
spectacle it's hard to fall asleep in
that one dude no way
that's a great church i've been to a big
ass mega church like that during their
like
mega you crazy yeah was it was it tight
was it fun
they have those like zipline kind of
things and then like things will
come floating down it's like a vegas
show dude yeah
a lot of [ __ ] money i would put 20
bones in there like just for that dude
i'd be like you know what
20 bucks for him doing that hey you give
him a great service
that's a great service some of these
mega churches are like cirque
shows yeah those just are boring half
the time be that way right
but it's entertaining it feels wrong for
me and you don't fall asleep though
true but it feels wrong for me i feel
like shouldn't this church i mean
shouldn't this money that i'm putting in
go to the less fortunate and not for
like
theatrical [ __ ] church is not a charity
all right i'll put you that right now
church
church is to save people and that just
saved me right now yeah that will save
they say me twice over dude
so you feel all right that's where your
money's going i feel okay that i just
saw a [ __ ] dumb ass just [ __ ]
zipline
but this dumbass is giving you this
sermon huh hey but check it out i've
also given thousands of dollars to a guy
that plays with pigeons on the corner of
alvarado in
seconds but that's a skill dude that's a
skill too
for a man to do that without shame and
think that's cool that's a skill
and he wasn't shaking he was literally
cool breeze that he probably rehearsed
that on the thursday before
that 40 bucks right there yeah you're
right and he didn't even he wasn't even
you know shaking the skills for the guy
[ __ ] pulling the rope
no the biggest skill is the hardest
there's the two assistant pastors that
didn't laugh as he was coming back
yeah oh you'd be cooler if he flew in
like superman they did
that would have been cool that would be
you know saying that this zipline thing
there
that it they didn't put because a lot of
people were upset too they're like what
the hell
this is where the money's going so he
was saying that that was already
installed there from donations from
previous
years and that that's the same [ __ ]
though yeah exactly
but they use that zipline thing for
shows like for like christmas shows
whatever
like an angel is like coming down yep so
but then for this one for this sermon
how he's talking about uh to get ready
for jesus return he was like you know
like i just thought
it would be the best thing to use this
prop to really
hey can you imagine him writing up the
sermon like you know it'll be dope this
is when i fly in
what if i come down like jesus as
symbolism
when i read matthew 5. boom i love it it
should have turned on the smoke machines
too
yeah oh that would have been a joke yeah
and [ __ ] lasers
you should be wearing all white like an
angel like wings yeah yeah yeah
like a wing like an angel outfit yeah
and you get the organ player just play
some like subtle chords in the back
yeah if you do it just go all the way
dude i i want to go to
church just to see the show sometimes
yeah because it's
so hilarious that sounds wrong it's
extra
[Music]
you